well you're looking live at Fox Square
here in midtown Manhattan home of
America's election headquarters we're
debuting this brand-new set on the
special midterm edition of the five all
right so you guys look like you're
bundled up it's 55 degrees out here I
just want the audience to know only 55
degrees Juan's wearing a scarf greg has
double layers and I think you have leg
warmers on is that correct this is an
electric blanket five degrees America in
New York you look like you're ready for
springtime
I'm ready one I'm ready this is hot
Jesse Watters runs hot I think that's
clear no no you know what Jesse's
wearing he's wearing a latex bodysuit
accidentaly know that Jesse really
wanted to wear that blue suit so he was
like I'm not gonna put a coat over my
costume what's great though about being
out here I got a great view of the gap I
can see what people are you know never
know what you're gonna need to buy in
the middle of there's already a great
crowd out there fabulous stuff we have
lots to get to but first Fox News Alert
with the highly anticipated midterm
elections just two days away President
Trump is continuing his furious campaign
schedule the president is wrapping up a
rally right now in Georgia before
heading to Tennessee later tonight here
are some of the highlights from just a
few minutes ago Republicans produced
jobs Democrats produce mobs
you've heard that you've seen it you've
seen it you've seen it and Tifa they
take the helmet off and they take the
armbands and you see these little arms
these little arm if the radical
resistance and that's what they are
radical resistance takes power they will
move immediately to reverse America's
progress and to eradicate all of the
gains that we've made you want more
caravans and you want more crime vote
Democrat it's very simple
if you want strong borders and Safe
Communities vote Republican all right
Greg I was thinking earlier today
President Trump led on in 2016 on a
law-and-order
an economic program and that's really
what this vid term has turned into at
the end too well here's two quick points
of all the people campaigning on both
sides the person who is least fatigued
is orange Superman yeah it's amazing and
I didn't notice that until I saw
President Obama out there and Joe Biden
who they looked winded after just a few
a few appearances but in terms of energy
they are Solar and he's nuclear he's
like the roadrunner and everybody else
is a or I wish I had 10 percent of this
energy having said that I think that the
the problem with a law-and-order kind of
stance is that it can be portrayed as
fear-mongering the problem is it looks
like fear-mongering because what you
want is a process and the opposite of
process is chaos so it is a natural
inclination to be fearful of chaos so I
think the proper framing of what Trump
is doing is that we are a party of
process due process law and order and if
you think that's fear-mongering then
you're sadly mistaken the other part of
that Jessi though is the economy we've
talked about the strong economic numbers
that came out on Friday even in the
polls today some of the last polls that
come out right before the election 65%
of people saying that this is a good
economy I don't know what the rest of
the people are thinking the strong
economy though has not shown up in the
polls heretofore however do you think it
will show up as a reason people vote on
Election Day
I do the economy's I think the second
biggest issue for most voters and you
can tell the president's extremely
excited you know when he's excited and
feeling good when he's talking about
skinny armed and Tifa and it was also
reminiscing about when he was running in
the primary against Republicans he was
always on the center of the stage you
can tell he's in a really good mood it
looks like as you were talking about the
polls of really tightens and even the
prognosticators are starting to hedge if
you look at the ABC news/washington post
poll the Congressional generic ballot
that's shrunk from 14 to 11 and now down
to seven and if you look at the other
two ones they have it at 7 and they have
it at 5 and if
plug those numbers into historical
predictors that does not translate into
a democratic victory that translates
into 15 seats to 22 seat pickup not
enough to make it happen right now the
Republicans are favored by 10 and 11
points on the economy and on border
security favored by 5 on taxes where
they're really looking bad is health
care they're down 15 points on health
care that's their fault they botched
repeal and replace they're also in
trouble because you know everybody
retired they thought this was going to
be a landslide Blueway victory last year
and trump wasn't looking good if all
these guys hadn't retired I would have
said the Republicans are looking at a
lock right now and Nate silver he's now
starting to hedge he said before 4 and 5
chances the Democrats take the house now
this is a direct quote extremely
possible that Republicans keep the house
and quote polls can be wrong so anything
could happen on Tuesday I don't know
what's going to happen I'll make my
prediction on Tuesday and you can take
one is one of the concerns for Democrats
that they have really high expectations
they might not be able to meet no I
think you want to get past
overconfidence and you want to make sure
that people get out to vote I mean what
you're really talking about here Dana is
turnout and everybody wants turnout what
we've already seen in terms of early
voting is high turnout in Texas four
million people have already voted
correct especially among young people
across the country high levels of
engagement so you can you know view it
in terms of like Texas you were
discussing where you see a higher
percentage of Republicans and Democrats
in that early turnout but in other
states given the high level of youthful
enthusiasm you're seeing more Democrats
turnout than Republicans in terms of the
issues I think what you're seeing in
terms of the advertising and we're
seeing a lot of ads this weekend is
again the president doubling down on the
fare issue the crime issue making ice or
ms-13 into the new Willie Horton or bad
guy who's coming to get you and your
family that intended to stir his base
but it's not among the top issues right
now health care remains overwhelmingly
top issue the number two issue is the
economy number three and I think this is
one that really touches me is if people
are concerned about the level of
division the God and what you see is
like when the president went to
Pittsburgh Rabbi Meir when he was
meeting with him he said this at this
Shabbat service yesterday in Pittsburgh
you said you know I said to the
president that hate hate speech leads to
hate action and what took place in this
sanctuary so I think lots of Americans
are concerned about the poor quality of
discourse and the kind of hatefulness
we're seeing in the country at the
moment right well I'm and that was
actually both sides weren't worried
about that Tami let me go to you about
that some of these Senate races though
are tied like the one in Missouri
President Trump is going to end his
final campaign rally of the spectrum
election on Tuesday on excuse me on
Monday night at 9:00 p.m. in Missouri do
you think that would be enough to tip
this in to Josh Hollies favor well you
know what the president's doing is what
King Newt Gingrich did in 94 he's trying
to nationalize this race this is what
makes will make the Republicans have a
better day so him going to every single
one of these states he himself
nationalizes it Newt Gingrich brought
together with a contract for America
Obama did it with Obamacare of you know
not did not good well for him
the President himself is the National
Iser but it's not his rhetoric
regardless of even how tightest state is
or not his rhetoric is not about
fear-mongering he's reflecting what the
American voter already feels as an
example 68 percent of likely voters
believe that illegal immigration is a
major problem that's last that was in
August 70% say stricter enforcement of
immigration laws is necessary that was
June in a Harvard Harris poll so the
president is reflecting back what
American people already care about in
wanting to make sure their lives are
safer it's not that you're afraid it's
that you notice what's gone wrong and
you want to fix it
so the president's presence we will find
will make a huge difference and of
course he that matters Florida has
mattered a great deal of course that's
effectively tied Nelson and Scott so
we're gonna find out how it works and I
think that the Democrats are making a
mistake in thinking that this new
enthusiasm only belongs to them they
thought they had that in 16 with Hillary
and they were mistaken
yes yes I do think because we're talking
about fear-mongering that the other side
is getting a huge free pass on this when
you look when I've seen ads that have
said that Republicans and this is going
but let's face it for decades now
Republicans have been accused of
destroying the environment going after
Social Security taking your health care
now it's enslaving women in putting
children in cages that's the new thing
Handmaid's Tale setting up camps
reminiscent of a very grim past these
are things and also let's not forget the
Democrats pioneered the the negative ad
with the Daisy ad the nuclear winter
against Goldwater so I think that you
know saying that the fear-mongering is
on one side it's a little bit of a
stretch let's go let's just go back to
the current date I'll leave Goldwater to
you in 64 but it's interesting to me
that the president chose immigration as
the focus because the economy wasn't
working for him on in this latest poll
what we see is among all voters 47 to 42
they prefer Democrats to handle to go
here there's a wide variety of potential
outcomes on Tuesday night we're gonna be
here at Fox Square to bring it all to
you